2026年09月26日(Sat)の投資レポートです。
ウォッチリストと検討中の銘柄、合わせて45銘柄を追いかけています。
今週、値動きが大きかったのは、東京エレクトロンがプラス4.8パーセント、Booking Holdings Inc.がプラス4.2パーセント、SCREENホールディングスがプラス3.3パーセントでした。
それでは、検討中の銘柄から見ていきます。
SKハイニックス（韓国取引所）です。
現在値はおよそ186万ウォン、前日比プラス1.2パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、買えるなら押し目を分割で。
ただし購入手段の確保が先。
日本の主要ネット証券では韓国株を扱っておらず、実務的には米国上場のマイクロン(MU)での代替を先に検討したい。
理由は、2026年4-6月期は売上が前年比257パーセント増、営業利益が557パーセント増。
HBM4の量産出荷を開始し、長期供給契約も拡大している。
UBSはNVIDIAの次世代Rubin向けHBM4で約70パーセントのシェアを取ると見ており、HBM全体でも50パーセント超を維持する見通し。
数字は出揃っているが、その分だけ既に株価に織り込まれている。
リスクとしては、2027〜2028年の供給過剰局面。
サムスン電子・マイクロンのキャッチアップによるシェア低下と価格下落。
対中輸出規制の変更が中国工場の運営に直撃する。
次に、共立メンテナンスです。
現在値はおよそ3260円、前日比プラス0.8パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、いま拾って良い水準。
業績と株価が逆行しており、ここは時間を味方にできる局面。
理由は、2026年3月期は売上2,752億円（プラス20.2パーセント）、営業利益248億円（プラス21.2パーセント）で3期連続の過去最高益。
にもかかわらず株価は2025年7月の3,785円から11月に2,663円まで下げ、その後2,800円台で推移している。
業績の伸びが株価に反映されていない状態が続いている。
リスクとしては、円高進行によるインバウンド需要の減退。
人手不足による出店ペースの鈍化。
ホテル用地・建築費の高騰で新規投資の採算が悪化する。
次に、アドバンテストです。
現在値はおよそ3万4000円、前日比プラス2.8パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、キオクシアやSKハイニックスを買うなら、その前にここを検討する価値がある。
ただし既に高値圏で、分割エントリー前提。
理由は、2026年4-6月期は過去最高益の見通し。
メモリメーカーが増産すれば必ずテスタが要るため、特定メーカーの勝ち負けに関係なく需要が乗ってくる位置にいる。
リスクとしては、メモリメーカーの設備投資が一巡した時点で受注が急減する。
円高進行による輸出採算の悪化。
次に、ディスコです。
現在値はおよそ5万4200円、前日比プラス1.7パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、押し目待ち。
指値を置いて待つ姿勢が合う。
理由は、ダイシング（切断）とグラインディング（薄化）で世界シェアの大半を握る。
NANDの多層化もHBMの積層も、チップを薄く削って重ねる工程が必ず入るため、メモリ増産の恩恵がそのまま乗る。
リスクとしては、設備投資サイクルの反転。
中国向け売上比率の高さと輸出規制の変更リスク。
次に、SCREENホールディングスです。
現在値はおよそ1万3700円、前日比プラス3.3パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、装置3社（アドバンテスト・ディスコ・SCREEN）の中では相対的に出遅れており、バリュエーション面で入りやすい。
理由は、洗浄装置で世界首位級。
NANDは層を積むほど穴が深くなり、その底まで洗う難度が上がるため、キオクシアの多層化がそのまま需要になる。
リスクとしては、メモリ以外（ロジック・パワー半導体）の設備投資が落ちると全体の稼働が下がる。
中国向け比率の高さ。
次に、荏原製作所です。
現在値はおよそ4440円、前日比マイナス1.6パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、半導体以外の事業（ポンプ・環境）が下支えするため、他の装置株より安心して打診できる。
理由は、CMP装置とドライ真空ポンプを持ち、半導体の平坦化工程を押さえている。
加えて水インフラ・エネルギー事業を併営しており、半導体市況が反転しても業績がゼロにならない。
リスクとしては、インフラ事業の大型案件の期ずれによる業績変動。
CMP装置での米アプライドマテリアルズとの競合。
次に、レゾナック・ホールディングスです。
現在値はおよそ1万5000円、前日比プラス0.7パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、後工程材料の比率が上がるまで待つ判断もある。
急がずウォッチから。
理由は、半導体の後工程材料（封止材・CMPスラリー等）で高シェア。
HBMの積層でもキオクシアの多層化でも材料は必ず消費されるが、石化事業の分離が進行中で会社の姿がまだ固まっていない。
リスクとしては、石化事業の切り離しが計画どおり進まない場合の財務負担。
ナフサ価格の変動。
次に、ハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズです。
現在値はおよそ6300円、前日比マイナス0.8パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、ヒューマノイドが話題になるたび跳ねる銘柄。
テーマが冷えている時に仕込むのが定石。
理由は、精密減速機（波動歯車装置）で世界シェア首位級。
TeslaのOptimusをはじめヒューマノイドの関節には必ず減速機が入るため、Teslaを買うより素直にロボット化の恩恵を受けられる位置にいる。
リスクとしては、ヒューマノイドの量産が想定より遅れた場合の失望売り。
中国メーカーによる減速機の内製化・低価格化。
次に、パナソニックホールディングスです。
現在値はおよそ4590円、前日比プラス1.8パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、Tesla関連としては期待しすぎない前提で。
配当を受け取りながら待つ銘柄。
理由は、Tesla向け車載電池の主要サプライヤーだが、北米工場の稼働はTeslaの販売動向に左右される。
Teslaが自動車からロボティクスへ軸足を移すと、電池の位置づけも変わる。
リスクとしては、Teslaの販売鈍化が電池事業の稼働率に直撃する。
北米工場の立ち上げコストが想定を超える。
次に、村田製作所です。
現在値はおよそ8020円、前日比プラス2.5パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、押し目で拾って長く持つ。
福井の新拠点が動き出したところで、次の成長への布石が打たれている。
理由は、積層セラミックコンデンサ（MLCC）で世界首位。
2026年3月に福井県越前市にセラコン特化の研究開発センターが竣工し、約530人体制で量産課題の解決に取り組んでいる。
AIサーバーもStarlink端末もスマホも、MLCCを使わない電子機器は存在しない。
リスクとしては、中国メーカーの技術キャッチアップによる価格下落。
スマホ需要の構造的な頭打ち。
次に、ファナックです。
現在値はおよそ5980円、前日比マイナス0.6パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、日本製造業の復活に賭けるなら本命の一角。
設備投資サイクルの底で拾いたい。
理由は、2026年7月16日、NVIDIAのCosmos連合に安川電機・川崎重工・クボタ・富士通らと並んで参加を表明。
工場の自動化データを持つ側として、フィジカルAIの中心に据えられた。
ジェンスン・ファンCEOは『日本が近代的な製造業を発明した。
いまその日本がAIファクトリーを建てている』と発言している。
リスクとしては、世界的な設備投資の減速。
中国の工作機械メーカーによる低価格帯からの侵食。
円高による輸出採算の悪化。
次に、安川電機です。
現在値はおよそ4480円、前日比マイナス0.6パーセントです。
投資タイミングは、ファナックとの二択なら、値動きの素直さでこちら。
決算で受注が底打ちしたのを確認してから。
理由は、同じくCosmos連合に参加。
サーボモータとインバータで世界首位級、産業用ロボットでも四強の一角。
受注の増減が早く決算に出るため、サイクルの転換点が読みやすい。
リスクとしては、中国メーカー（汇川技術等）とのシェア争いによる価格下落。
設備投資サイクルの下降局面。
以上で今回の投資レポートを終わります。
またお聞きください。